why do you think Game of Thrones has
been so successful because it's really
well written it really is and I can't
say that about everything I'm involved
in the production value is astonishing
the storylines are great it's just a
really really good show that's why what
you enjoy as an actor being in the show
about in your character was it the panic
appeals to you the most
well Tywin's a great character and you
know everything about him has not been
revealed in one go if you know what I
mean you learn a bit more about him each
time with each series and with each
scene in each episodes people talking
about about him as being you know the
the villain I'm not sure that he is I
might be taken by surprise yet I don't
know but it's just it's so well-written
I can't press that point more you know
because we spend a lot of time in this
business trying to make a silk purse out
of a pig's ear if you understand the
expression and this either is a silk
purse I mean really the quality the
standard of the scripts and quality the
writing is phenomenal it really really
is and it's a joy to do I know what's
happening in the next series that I
start shooting in about two weeks time
what can we look forward to things don't
improve relations don't improve between
Tyrion and me what are you working on
next after two game of friends
I've just finished another series for
HBO called strike back which we shot in
South Africa and then when I finished
Game of Thrones I think I've got a
couple of films in Australia strike now
is it's if you remember the
professionals
the two principal guys in it like
special services guys who are always
being sent off to trouble spots in the
world and that's what they're doing in
South Africa but I can't really tell you
any more about that but there's a lot of
action and a lot of sex in it in rather
glorious locations well look forward to
seeing that and the next season of Game
of Thrones and thanks for speaking to us
thank you very much thank you
you